meanwhile President Trump will announce
the next nominee to the Supreme Court
tonight at the White House mr. Trump
said yesterday he is still looking at a
group of finalists let's say it's the
poor people but and they're excellent
everyone you can't go wrong but I'm
getting very close to making a final
decision
sources tell CBS News the poor
contenders are federal appeals court
judges Amy Kony Barrett Raymond Catholic
Brett Kavanaugh and Thomas Hardiman Jan
Crawford is at the Supreme Court Jan
good morning well good morning John so
you know in this group of four I mean
we've seen these contenders kind of rise
and fall and rise and fall again but I
mean from the beginning one of those
names has been at or near the top and
that's judge Brett Kavanaugh he's kind
of got all the boxes checked he's got
those elite legal credentials that the
president says he wants Yale College
Yale Law School he clerked for Justice
Kennedy and he someone has seen us it'd
be a real intellectual heavyweight on
the Supreme Court but he's very
experienced and that weirdly enough is a
knock against him he's written more than
300 opinions he worked in the Bush White
House he worked for independent counsel
Ken Starr so Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has flagged that his
confirmation might take a little while
longer because he's got a record and
that's kind of kept him from kind of
sealing the deal and left an opening for
some of these other contenders like
Judge Thomas hardiment the president
really likes his personal story he would
bring diversity to the court he's kind
of the first he'd be the first justice
who's outside the Ivy League he went to
Notre Dame Georgetown Law School first
person in a family who went to college
he actually helped pay for it by driving
a taxi so he's a really interesting
choice from Pennsylvania the other two
kind of now we think maybe have fallen a
little bit off the list
Raymond Catholic and Judge Amy Coney
Barrett Catholics there's some concern
that he might drift to the left a little
bit he's unproven which some of these
Republican nominees have done once
they've gotten up on the Supreme Court
and then judge Barrett the the president
is very enamored with her personal story
she'd be the first conservative woman on
the Supreme Court but he's thinking
maybe she would be the pick for the next
time she's 46 years old he's got plenty
of time he thinks to get another pick so
that's kind of where we are right now
all right Jan Crawford Forrest
at the Supreme Court a little more than
14 hours so we got a decision CBS News
will bring you a special report when
President Trump announces his nominee
for the Supreme Court tonight Jeff Glor
will anchor from Washington you can see
it at 9:00 p.m. Eastern 8:00 central
right here on CBS